(audience applauding)
- Our next guest,
almost took over the role
of Steve in Blues Clues.
I didn't even know that.
Please welcome, Justin Long.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- I was on time?
- [Drew] Yes!
(Drew laughing)
- Oh my god. Am I late?
- No, you're not.
(Justin and Drew laughing)
- You know I'm classic.
- Is it?
- No. (laughing)
Everyone.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
I mean,
Hi.
- Hi.
(Justin and Drew laughing)
(audience cheering)
(indistinct)
- Thanks for jumping into this with me.
- Oh man. Thanks for asking me.
- We haven't seen each other.
- Yeah.
- We've been texting and audio messages.
- Yes.
- Which I don't know how to keep.
- Oh, it there's a little
blue thing that says, keep.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
I didn't mean that in a condescending way,
- No.
because it's
easy to miss. It says keep.
But sometimes when you keep messages,
like Christian, Doggy, he gets a little-
- His brother.
- My brother.
Sorry, I forgot we were
on a TV, that's right,
- TV show, with people.
(Drew laughing)
- We're reuniting on national television.
- Like you do.
- Yeah!
- You know how when
(audience applauding)
your former love, hosts a
show and yeah, this is wild.
- Well you left me this audio message.
And it was so funny and I
meant to try and save it,
- Aww.
- to play,
only to realize, I don't
know how to do that.
- Little blue keep. Yeah.
- Okay.
- Thank you. See, you learn something
- new every day.
- Well I'm glad I came.
Thank you everyone.
(Drew laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Okay. So I was talking
with Mike Birbiglia,
the amazing comedian.
- Very funny. Yes.
- And we did this movie with
him, Going the Distance.
And so Bribigs and I
are just chit-chatting.
- Yeah.
- We're doing a social piece.
It wasn't a part of the show.
- Oh.
And in it, I compliment you,
and I heard you heard about it.
- Well, yeah, people sent it to me.
- 'Cause it went everywhere.
- Well, it was the most flattering.
It was, for you to be
saying how funny I am.
Now, first of all, I feel
like I have to be really funny
to live up to that hype.
- I know,
isn't that the worst?
- Yeah.
- You're so funny!
- Yeah, I know.
What do you got?
(audience laughing)
What do you got? Aw, that's it?
That's what he said?
He said a thing about...
Now he's been talking about
how to keep text messages.
(Drew and Justin laughing)
- Listen, all of us who
need IT, are grateful.
- Yeah, okay. Well, you're welcome.
But it was so flattering.
I think of you and I wanted to say,
I said it as I was watching
it, you're the funny one.
You are one of the funniest
people I've ever met.
Everyone knows this,
(audience applauding)
'cause they watch your show.
You go toe to toe when you
were a kid with Letterman.
Not many people can do that.
Yeah. I'll never forget the laughs.
Yeah. We had a lot of laughs.
- That's what we that's what we did.
We laughed so much.
- We laughed all the time.
Yeah.
- That was so much a
part of our connection,
- was that,
- Mm-hmm.
- we love funny people.
- Yeah.
- We enjoy laughing at all times.
I feel like even when things
get dark, I laugh harder.
- Mm-hmm, yes. Yeah, you can get dark.
Which people don't know
on a daytime show maybe,
but you are one of the
darkest funny people.
I've ever known.
- Yes! I have a dark side.
- Yes. Yeah, I don't
know if you know that.
Well, tell them something
darkly funny right now,
or something really like tragically funny.
(Drew laughing)
Let's get into it.
- Oh, god.
- But yeah, we laughed
a lot and it's funny
because I've been going back over
all the time we've known each other
and what are we gonna talk about?
This is very strange.
- It is surreal.
- It is very surreal.
- I'm so grateful that
you would do this with me.
- Oh, are you kidding? Of course.
I'm grateful you wanted me.
(audience applauding)
And thanks to you guys for coming.
- And you know it's funny,
when we launched the show,
You know, in the industry,
everyone's like, "Who's your first guest?"
Like it's some measuring contest.
- Yeah.
And you see what I was doing there?
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Ah ha.
- Yeah a little uh-huh?
- Uh-huh.
- Ohh?
- Ohh.
- That's funny. I said, did I not say?
(Drew and Justin laughing)
- And I was like, God,
it's September 2020.
We're in a pandemic.
- Yeah.
People aren't coming
out. It's the hardest,
most difficult time in the
world on a global level.
Everything is at stake.
We're in the fourth quarter
of the game of our life.
- Now make this funny.
(Drew laughing)
This is the challenge.
You've set yourself up now. (laughing)
- So I asked Cameron and Lucy to come on.
As the first guests.
- Yeah, yeah. Makes sense.
- Because I thought my
professional endeavors are...
That I hold them so high with them.
- Yeah.
- And we've been through
birth, life, death, divorced,
- Yeah.
- marriage, kids,
- Yes.
- vacations, work.
- Yeah, Poo.
- What?
- You and Poo.
Auntie Poo Poo.
That's Cameron Diaz.
- Yeah.
- She's Auntie Poo Poo.
- Yeah, sure. Okay.
- Poo poo.
And so I asked them.
- Yeah.
And I just thought,
"What about if this year we could
start the show together?"
- Aww.
Because I think
relationships in this world
are one of the most universal subjects.
Everyone is out there either in love,
looking for love, looking
for relationships.
But relationships transcend
also the romantic.
You are working with a coworker
or you have a best friend or a parent.
We're all in relationships.
- I love that we've maintained our love
because I don't think it'll ever,
I know from my end
it'll never go anywhere.
I'll love you always, you know?
And so,
(audience applauding)
I'm glad that we're
able to still have that.
I mean that. I'll always love you.
- I will always love you so much.
Yeah, I know.
(audience applauding)
- You are so important to me.
- I know, I know.
- All right.
It's true. All right.
(Drew crying)
(audience applauding)
- I love you.
I know that you know that. You know that.
- I'm so grateful.
- No you know that.
I really am. I'm really grateful.
Oh, I'm glad. Me too.
- I feel like we've been
through so much together too.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know?
I felt like when we used
to talk and FaceTime,
I was always like, "I've really
grown up Justin." (laughing)
Like, I always wanted to prove to you,
what a different person I
was, than when we dated.
- You were the best.
- We had so much fun.
- It's fine.
No, I know, it was a different time.
- But we were more hedonistic,
(Drew and Justin laughing)
more immature.
- Yeah.
- We would get together.
We would break up.
- Yeah.
- There was chaos.
It was hella fun.
- Fun chaos.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. Well it's, yeah,
most hedonism is fun.
(Drew and Justin laughing)
There's not a lot of bad hedonism.
(audience applauding)
- I don't think if you look at-
- Yes, for hedonism! (clapping) Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
- It's true. When you look at-
- Get some Viking helmets.
Like, "Guys I..."
(Drew and Justin laughing)
- If you look at hedonism
in the dictionary,
it's not upsetting.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm boring.
(Drew laughing)
Yeah. You're doing it wrong then.
We had a blast and I
cherish that time. I do.
- I mean, when we first met, you were such
a bachelor that you...
(Drew and Justin laughing)
- I was 20! When we first
met, you know I was 20, 21?
Yeah.
- You had an overstuffed,
trash compactor, (sniffing)
and holes in your sheet,
and an outdoor gym.
I'm just gonna say.
(Drew and Justin laughing)
- Yeah, that is true.
I remember you looking at me
once. I had the best night.
We went out and a night of hedonism.
And I put on a hat. Do you
remember this baseball cap?
- You're not gonna believe
the full circle of this.
Yes, you put on a baseball
cap and what did I do?
- Well you are one of the
least judgemental people.
You allowed me to be. You
are such a safe person
and never judged.
- Thank you.
And there was this one
moment you looked at me.
We've been having fun and
I was like, "Oh my cap!"
My University of Texas.
Shout out. I have nothing to do with them,
(audience cheering)
but it was a University...
Yes!
- UT!
- UT, yeah!
- Go Longhorns!
- Yeah. I put it on and
you just went, "Nope."
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
And I went, "What do you mean?"
"No baseball cap."
All right. Well, I can do this.
All these other things are so fun.
We were getting along,
like I've never gotten along with anyone.
- [Drew] Yeah.
And so, okay, I don't have
to wear a baseball cap.
I'll wear a propeller beanie instead,
(Drew and Justin laughing)
a less embarrassing thing.
- Do you know what's so funny?
- Yeah?
- I wear baseball caps now.
(hands clapping)
- Full circle.
(audience applauding)
- I get it.
- Yeah.
- Yes to baseball caps.
- And we had so many
nicknames for each other.
- Yes!
- I can't text you anymore
(Justin laughing)
because I've got you
as 15 different names.
So that's why I was freaking out
- Ohh. Oh.
- trying to text you back.
And it wouldn't go through
because you're under
too many contacts,
- Oh really?
- because we had too many names.
- We, I have you under...
Yeah. Yes, that is true.
But the first name I remember,
for years I knew you as...
You know what I'm gonna say?
- No.
- I was chuckles?
- Yes.
- The Playboy night?
- Yes!
- Oh, we all went to the Playboy Mansion.
- Yes
- This is, by the way,
hedonism!
- Well there you go.
(audience laughing)
- Guess where hedonism is
living its best life? Or was.
- Yeah, it was.
- Was.
Long gone are all these days.
- Yeah, I know. I know.
- I'm telling you why was
the '80s and '90s so good?
- I know. Well.
Yes! I know. (clapping)
(Drew laughing)
No sorry.
(audience applauding)
Yeah. Well we met before.
So we all went. Our friend, Sam Rockwell.
- Who won an academy award.
And he was the lead in Charlie's Angels.
(audience cheering)
- Yes.
- He's the villain, Knox.
And my casting director, best friend,
and I were obsessed with him.
So we were like can we-
- Justine, the best.
- Justine, let's make him
the lead in this movie.
And we always knew that
he was the most talented
most dynamic actor. And finally
he won his Academy Award.
- Yeah, so deserved. Long deserved.
But we had just done Galaxy
Quest and we had done a play.
So, Sam and I, became really good friends.
And one night, he said,
"Hey, you wanna go out? I'm
gonna meet some friends.
You gotta meet drew. You gotta meet drew."
And I said, "Oh yeah,
you know, I'd love to!"
I was at 21. I was just out
to LA for the first time.
- Just getting out of your diapers.
- Getting out of the diapers.
I was just completing puberty.
Almost completing puberty.
(Drew laughing)
And I thought-
- You know what? You were
a late bloomer though.
- I was.
- That was sort of...
You know
(Justin laughing)
- I was a late bloomer.
Yes. Let's talk about that.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Let's unpack that.
Yeah. Thank you.
- And yet, you still look, really young.
- Oh, you-
- I mean that compliment- (laughing)
- Okay! Okay.
- I mean that complimentary. You do.
In your intro,
- Oh.
- the tidbit about Blues
Clues, I'm like, "Of course."
You still look like...
- Hey everyone! Hey Blue.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Yeah. I'm like, it's gonna get...
As you age with a young
face, it's not a great...
But you look...
So, we were all talking backstage,
- You look so pretty. So good.
- Really?!
- So pretty.
- Oh my God, thank you.
That means so much to me. You
know what I've done to myself,
so I'm just hanging on.
- That's amazing. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
I know, considering,
- Kind of is.
- all the hedonism.
- I think it's all gonna turn a corner
in like a matter of a day.
That's what I feel like.
One day, it's just gonna be like.
(imitating building collapsing)
(Drew and audience laughing)
- Ahhh.
- Ahhh. Yeah.
- I know. It's really true.
- Yeah.
- It's like bad.
- It's held together, but-
- Wait, what was your
nickname? What was my nickname?
Well we gave each other Play...
'Cause we were going
on the Playboy Mansion.
So we gave each other Playboy names.
- Right.
We thought we'd really
like embrace the night out
at the Playboy Mansion. And you were...
I can't believe you don't remember this.
- What was it?
- Whiskey,
Va-
- Guess?
- Yes.
- Whiskey Vargas!
- Yeah. Great, you got it!
- Yeah! (laughing)
Oh my God our game nights.
Yes!
- Oh, God. I was a nutcase.
I used to just drink and be like, Play!
(audience laughing)
I was that guy. I wasn't-
(audience applauding)
- It's true. It was wild,
but I remember playing
with Quentin Tarantino.
- Oh my God! We played with Quentin.
- Yeah. Catch Phrase or?
- Oh, no.
- It was,
- Oh, God.
Apples to Apples! Was it Apples to Apples?
- It could have been Apples to Apples.
It was that... Cranium!
- Cranium! Yes.
And he was going, "Here's was it is!"
And he was all juiced
up and wild and he...
(water spraying)
(everyone laughing)
(audience applauding)
- Yes!
- I live for that. By the way,
that is the greatest compliment to get.
A genuine Drew spit-take.
The best. You still
have it in there, sorry.
- Ah, finally.
(audience applauding)
But if you know, Quentin Tarantino,
who is a genius,
- Yeah.
but he is like, (laughing)
fully loaded.
- Yes. Yeah.
- He's a person who like,
everything is on 20.
- Yes, yeah. "The stakes are so high."
And it's like, "It's a game."
(Drew laughing)
But we would get...
We had the best game nights.
(upbeat music)